we're gonna get stuck right into these
no long preamble I would love you
underneath you're headed to have a kite
in a rhombus drawn and your initial
thought might be why are we dealing with
these two quadrilaterals together we've
looked at so far squares rectangles
triangles parallelograms what do we look
at most recently it's remember yesterday
we looked at trapezius thank you very
much why would we do kites and rhombuses
at the same time any suggestions it kind
of the same we I'm going to agree with
you there do remember yesterday we
looked at this idea that every area
formula is interconnected come in grab a
seat boys every area formula is related
to every other one some of the
connections are more obvious than others
the kind of the rhombus we're going to
deal with together because scuse me
they each share a property which results
in the same formula and you'll see why
in a second so when you take a kind or
rhombus just draw it up
remember the key feature of a kind is
that you've got these two sides being
the same adjacent sides being equally
and these two also being equal if you
took those two pairs and made them equal
to each other then you'd end up with a
rhombus all four sides are equal in
length what I'd like us to do is to draw
the diagonals of these two shapes can we
please draw the diagonals of these two
shapes
now if you have actually used a ruler
and you've drawn your kite it's actually
a kite like you've measured out you've
drawn your rhombus it's actually a
rhombus every side matches then when you
draw your diagonals you cannot help but
notice that the dials have this nice
peculiar relationship with each other
they meet at a certain angle can anyone
tell me what that angle is
senator it's 90 degrees right so we
would say these diagonals are what's the
word when two things are 90 degrees yeah
you know perpendicular thank you very
much can you please indicate for me this
is perpendicular and this is
perpendicular okay so we've got out
right angles now remember what we had a
look yesterday you can take a shape like
a trapezium and you can cut it up you
can rearrange it so that you get a shape
that's easier to calculate we're gonna
do the same thing here we're going to do
it twice have a look over here let's
look at the kite right do you notice the
kite has a kind of symmetry do you see
that it's symmetrical like these guys
are the same but these guys are the same
right so what I want you to if you care
if you've got another color that'll be
enormously helpful what I'd like you to
shade in with me is that these four
triangles here are not actually four
triangles it's two triangles done twice
see this guy over here I'm gonna shade
this one off the top in red this red
triangle is identical to this red
triangle you see that they just mirror
images of each other and it's the same
deal with the ones on the bottom these
two triangles here are equal to these
two triangles here now we have a fancy
name for this which we're going to deal
with a little more next year but I'm
going to tell you what the word is now
so that hit top last time you're like oh
remember that things too we said when
these triangles are the same in every
single way they're the same size same
dimensions all that we call them call
grew and conquer it it's a bit of a
funny kind of word here's how you spell
it see OMG are you empty
they're kagura identical in every way
including their area so what we can do
is if you like just eyes up for a second
and watch this part you can then go back
to enjoy your intro imagine taking this
red triangle here and ripping it off and
then spinning it around so it fit over
here can you see it would fit in nicely
on that corner
can you do that you can do it on your
own and you can match it with this
orange one down the bottom I could take
this left hand tray or sort of rip it
off and then spin it around so it fits
over here okay so now having moved this
shape over here I'm just going to do my
very best with this post up perfect okay
what shape is that that's a rectangle
right all we need is its base and its
height and we're there okay so in a kite
or in a black would go here it is our
rhombus
we'll usually call these two diagonals x
and y so if I put an X all the way
across there and a Y which goes all the
way up and down what is the height of
the rectangle that we've drawn not our
toe commissions just very
straightforward the new rectangle on the
right hand side how tall is it look mmm
Krishna what do you say
ah okay so you've already gone to the
next time haven't you the height is why
what did you get where did Christian I
get half of X from where is that yeah
where do you sit yep
very good so we've got this rectangle
it's half sorry it's why all the way
from the top to the bottom and then when
you have a look at this rectangle it's
half as wide as the original kite we
started with so what's the area of this
kite it's the same as the area of that
rectangle base times height it's going
to be half x times y we could just write
it as half X Y or even X Y on two if you
wanted to not write the one you want to
be super super lazy when you have a look
hopefully you can see everything that we
said over here I'm gonna ask you to UM
to shade this in just the same
everything we said over here about the
client is also true of the rhombus you
still got the same conquer it shapes are
identical triangles up the top you could
do the same flip around same down the
bottom you can just flip it around and
in fact this area formula so long as you
know the lengths of those diagonals it
works not just for the kite but also for
the rhombus exactly the same deal
because we can do the same rearrangement
so I'm just gonna finish coloring in the
appropriate rectangles now yeah this is
an interesting thing right because we
made the top and the bottom equivalent
to each other not only are these two
triangles equal to each other these two
are as well right so you could you just
get four worked out 40 no four triangles
makes two rectangles all together it'll
be the same